[Musique]
ces maladies elles ont disparu
de toute façon et non la maladière
centre a disparu suivant les cas soit
presque plus personne ne les attrape
soit on a endigué les grandes épidémies
et vous savez pourquoi
parce que les gens sont vaccinés mais
pas assez parce qu'il ya encore des
morts ou des séquelles qui sont
évitables
c'est pour ça qu'il faut continuer
l'effort et nous on a de la chance qu'on
a accès à ces vaccins là mais c'est loin
d'être le cas partout dans le monde du
coup il ya des endroits dans le monde où
des maladies comme la polio par exemple
ça existe encore et après un voyage on
peut ramener la maladie et la
transmettre et des voyages de plus en
plus attention rien qu'en france des cas
de rougeole des hépatites des infections
à méningocoques y en a encore
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]